[Music]
and all you need is love new submitted
by Mikasa
July the FDA sent a warning letter to a
bakery after they included love in their
ingredient list I get it excuse me
love is not that ingredient you're
trying to be creative but don't [ __ ]
with me - they're being a little bit too
hipstery yeah it's not that yeah I mean
drugs I always say that when things are
cooked with love it tastes better and
you can taste them where can you buy
this lo you have to find it in your
heart I'll give you evidence all right
eat David's cookie and go to one of the
cafes here and eat there cooking but his
cookie makes me wanna throw up all the
time really that's funny because you ate
my food twice and I threw it up no you
ate ice cream food he loved it so much I
wanted all his recipes you wouldn't come
back
I was being polite as my mom was there
she taught me better but really because
I have a picture of my supposed to have
your phone oh I heard you asking him to
come over and cook all the time and how
could it into my me that sounds like
[ __ ] bring your chili bring your mac
and cheese
why you're gonna turn against me girl we
all enjoy David's cooking I'm just
trying to prove a point when food is
made from love
it tastes ten times better than an angry
Chinese cook that just lost his gambling
money
especially drunk but Bart's always
talking about his mom make some food and
it tastes like carpet that's not coming
from love it's coming from health
consciousness because she loves it no
it's coming from [ __ ] Confucius say
yeah this way there's no love in it it's
coming from he has to be healthier he's
gonna die it's coming from beer anyways
this bakery they create no I like it I'm
kidding
you all heard of folks Gio was lying I'm
a [ __ ] lawyer
so this bakery is called Neshoba Brook
bakery and it's based in Massachusetts
so the FDA went over there and they were
inspecting and apparently there were
some unsanitary things could happen
so they have to fix that and part of
that like part of that notice was the
fact that they were saying that they
can't list love as an ingredient because
it might be deceptive of course I mean
it make sense because people might say
what is this love is it gluten-free this
is the granola where love is listed this
is what it looks like and then this is
the ingredient so they didn't pass the
health and safety so I get to given the
warning to fix all of the things that
they needed to fix and one of them was
the fact that they have love in the
ingredient yeah because when people do
that they put is a tag line versus an
actual ingredient yeah and make sense
that could become for all we know
because it is called a love juice and
the granola sticky I was gonna say the
rat [ __ ] cuz it I imagine the FDA coming
in going up okay you got a road in say
got cut garage you got it in what is
this is that what you call this [ __ ]
cockroach eroded [ __ ] love all right if
there's a certain amount that's allowed
right but it's for a huge batch of
cereal and they say like there's an
acceptable amount of point whatever
percent in that to be right [ __ ] but
it's dissipated over like 100,000 pounds
of cereal I don't see it and I'm not
[ __ ] vomiting out of my butthole
I guess alright yeah ever since you guys
had Tyco do you guys still go out to eat
there we can't go out he can't go out
yet so we just mates or we make food at
home that's the best way that's why I
can't be yo guys quit thank you very
much cheek good my mom told me that your
mom has manners you animal well that's
like a Korean thing I usually when they
have kids or something you would come on
when you make them a meal it just makes
it easier for them no I know where
that's enclosed oh but we don't eat out
though yeah oh oh those houses like
germs and a bunch of people that are
sick like if it everyone's congregating
in one spot that's how we just go out to
open like fuel today so I say you don't
take your kids unless they need to go
because then people in the waiting room
or to the doctors are you don't think
that I don't think your kids are doctor
unless they really have to go yeah they
say you can't go to enclosed public
spaces
so those hikes Works's openers cool and
the closest thing we went to a
restaurant is like
having tiger in the backseat and we go
through the drive-through up in and out
yeah and even our his pharmacist or
where does a pediatrician they have a
sick room that's cool oh yeah once he
gets a shot we can go to like
restaurants and all that stuff second
papi that again November you have to be
be warm be cold
no dewormed I don't know it depends one
month my it they say one month but then
for them it's two months for this guy
it's two months he's like an animal I
feel like I'm learning all over again
through you guys yeah don't even
vaccinate him just she's vinegar and
blueberries yep and Windex and
moonstones
yeah apple cider vinegar blueberries and
honey yeah I heard that and I'll come
over and play a spiritual song with my
flute to bless him with good health yep
that already sounds sick anyway so the
owner of this bakery was saying that
this whole thing like to love ingredient
thing was just he said I just felt so
George Orwell and he said quote I really
like that we list love in the granola
people ask us what makes it so good put
it in the tagline yeah it's kind of nice
that is this is an artisan artisan
bakery and then you can say that there's
love in it and then put the smile on
people's faces that's what I say all the
time too because when I make stuff I was
like oh do you guys like it's like yeah
it's really good I was like it's made
with love guys I like your stuff thank
you have you ever tried cooking yourself
when you're upset and then you eat it
and it tastes like [ __ ] yeah you know if
I'm upset and I'm cooking and if it make
while I'm cooking I start feeling better
it tastes good but if I'm mad throughout
the whole thing it's a bar you know I
made this these chili cheese fries and
you know the same cheese sauce that I
used for the mac is that for the chili
cheese fries now so we don't take like
milk just like shredded cheddar I take
the white Gouda cheese sauce and I put
it over the chip and see it's so [ __ ]
good dude oh my god that's it my mom
says when the food's really really spicy
at least in our household if the food's
really spicy or like the man you must
piss when you were cooking this it was
like cereal
habanero cereal narrow
your crotch actually we know though it
tastes like everything every time you
read something spicy they tell you to
drink milk and then a cereal try it
sided for it would not become a parent I
want my kid to take food to school that
I made that's [ __ ] better than all
the other [ __ ] that that other kids are
gonna eat okay they're so stupid he's
gonna throw it away cuz he wants a
little kids gonna know what's up because
when I was a kid packed embarrassing
[ __ ] like the ethnic she like king pot
Oh 100% but now it's different though
people want that [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
octopus don't want that [ __ ] they're
kids yeah I remember I was gonna bring
like this kimchi fried rice my mom made
and then my dad told me not to bring it
cuz he said that I was gonna get made
fun of but I wanted to bring it cuz I'm
so I love this [ __ ] cuz I wanted to eat
it at lunch I wanted to eat your lunch
bug bro you know he's gonna make fun of
his culture all my mom's keep up is the
[ __ ] though I think that ships I like
you know because you don't ever bring us
on I I could try to make my mom's keep
others heart no you just said your mom's
bomb why would I want yours
you're just not ready
yeah I just bring it for Bart in a nice
little little little thing there here
you go Bart don't you [ __ ] fever
you're cut off too I remember before you
got pregnant you were trying to cook
more often
no I'm trying to just get my life
together right now with [ __ ] no sleep
yeah we should go past that you'll work
on that later yeah I mean you can't even
eat right now anything all you made your
salsa nothing's delicious
I made salsa Oh muy fantastico puta you
to have the perfect guys to start
cooking for though because the probably
won't critique your [ __ ] and eat it and
eat it all there's nothing that I've
made that's pretty [ __ ] my even if
it's [ __ ] ass [ __ ] oh dang it
I'll let you know if it's good and I'll
let you know if it's ass [ __ ] boss so
you both name your dessert I forgot what
it was ice cream sandwich and spam
musubi it's good no I think I had those
two things that you made I mean you made
a tuna sandwich Castro like that that's
just like stoner food like I like that
[ __ ] it feels like a 1960s party item
yeah
like I want to scoop that [ __ ] with like
a bunch of Lay's potato chips and a coke
she made enchiladas and chilaquiles
before I was pretty good are you still
always make enchiladas and ice always
make rice and I saw using beans I love
making now I just hate being in the
kitchen night why how can you hate
something so awesome because I just
don't like it I don't know and now I'm
owning it I'm like okay I don't care I'm
a Mexican I can't or doesn't cook I can
cook I just don't like cooking and then
now I just get criticized for like ha
you don't make food for your little
child it's like I married someone that
loves cooking so he can make yeah I
think when one person takes over both
people don't need to do it yeah I like
cooking because I like people eating
something that I created and enjoying it
yeah that's the part that I'm like buck
I'm not so yeah I just haven't found the
passion for it but I think that
satisfaction is what I want coz that's
my mom to like I see my mom like what I
eat something she waits for my reaction
its nurturing that's what I do here
yesterday I made the [ __ ] lettuce and
I gave it to your mama and I was like
you gonna like it and she like that is
we mean so I found uh I found a [ __ ]
head of lettuce in our refrigerator what
the [ __ ] am I gonna do with this
[ __ ] I was like well [ __ ] and I
needed some greens cuz I'm trying to get
greens and fiber so I took it and I
chopped up some garlic through some
olive oil and then some sesame oil and
like salt pepper whatever i seasoned it
and then cannot pretty good wait you
mean you stir-fried lettuce or you made
lettuce wraps
you know I stir-fried the like romaine
lettuce I never did that before I
treated it like it was like Chinese
greens of some sort that's interesting
Oh what the [ __ ] am I gonna do with this
[ __ ] in China yeah I cook because I
want something like a flavor but I can't
get it at a store and I think of the
flavor I think for me the reason why I
don't like cooking your food in general
is that I never really have much of an
appetite like I know I get hungry but
it's not like I generally crave for
certain things it has to please you like
it's a drug when you smell it when you
put it in your mouth all that stuff and
you go are you Mel
I feel like I didn't enjoy that but I
don't feel that all the time and it's
very rare it's very like also to like if
you like cooking too it's fun because
you get to try new things like when I
made them dinner he was on macros so I
flipped what I was gonna make and then I
had to think about okay well how can I
create something with low fat high
protein that's still Korean and so I did
Korean wraps but then I didn't do
brisket and I didn't do pork belly I did
New York Strip and I did pork loin
instead so it's like literally a third
of the fact you know so it was like a
different so it's fun and exciting you
know it's probably like we we've been
doing it since we were a little like
helping our moms in the kitchen and all
that my mom never cooked it's kind of
like that yeah and I remember I would
get rice and put butter and soy sauce
and mix that [ __ ] and be my grandma in
the morning cuz she would feed me that
[ __ ] doo butter soy sauce and a fried
egg and you mix that [ __ ] and that
Korean seaweed oh yeah and then you get
the cream see where you put that with a
piece of kimchi in there good hey guys
thanks for watching that last episode
did you love it I know you did but guess
what you can also follow us on our
personal social media accounts with the
links in the description box below so go
follow all of us now to watch more
videos
[Music]